hello this is Allison Davis at Stanford
Graduate School of Business welcome to
our webinar on the masters and
electrical engineering and MBA joint
degree program we are going to be
together here for 45 minutes and thank
you to so many of you who sent questions
in advance we will do our best to answer
as many questions as we can
I'm here with my colleagues from the
other parts of the Graduate School of
Business as well as the engineering
school so we have a great panel here
today Becky Sharbot who is associate
director of Career Management Center
Jack Edwards who is the director of
financial aid at the Graduate School of
Business
Katie Clemmy who is the associate
director of Graduate Admissions at
School of Engineering Department of
Electrical Engineering and Mary Aleksey
who is the associate director at the
Graduate School of Business for the
joint and dual degree program and I'm
particularly going to point out Mary
because she will if you do this joint
degree program will really become your
new best friend because she's the person
at the Graduate School of Business who
advises students as they make their way
through the two degrees and we as you
may know this is one of several joint
degrees that that Stanford offers as we
are a big big believer in
interdisciplinary education so I'm going
to start with Mary and asking you Mary
this is a new joint degree why why is
Stanford offering this degree with what
is the purpose and the value of it hi
everybody and welcome again this is Mary
Alexei and in regards to why we're
offering this joint degree I think it's
for several reasons
Stanford is known well known for being
an incubator for new technology ventures
and this new degree program
is designed to foster that innovation
that Springs naturally from two of the
university's world-class programs namely
the Graduate School of Business and the
electrical engineering department the
purpose of the program is to provide an
opportunity for electrical engineers to
develop the necessary skills to become
managers and entrepreneurs and for
technologically inclined business
students to gain a solid background in
electrical engineering by coordinating
both of these degrees in a more focused
approach and so for students that are
admitted into the joint degree program
they should be able to complete the
degree within nine quarters which
equates to a savings of approximately
two quarters since on their own the GSB
takes six quarters to complete the NBA
and the electrical engineering ms takes
approximately five to six quarters great
thank you Mary and for both Katie who's
the Graduate Admissions Director from
engineering and again for Mary who's
this joint degree really meant for who
is the ideal candidate for this
Thanks this is Katie Clemmy speaking and
I think for the ideal candidate we're
really looking for someone that has a
strong technical background someone that
also likes to think really about this
big picture so these are students who'd
want to go beyond the technical aspects
of their jobs and really have a vision
for how they want to use the technical
knowledge that they have to really make
an impact I think in many ways you can
think about it as you know in a marriage
between the technology and engineering
side and the business side of Industry
Mary any comments I think Katie covered
it perfectly and you know we're hearing
from engineers that know they're
eventually going to be managing people
and they want to make sure they're well
equipped for those challenges that come
along with leadership and management
responsibilities Becky from the career
end of it what would be the career
opportunities and career paths for
students who are participating the joint
degree definitely thank you yes thank
you
or management and leave the employee
relations and recruiting team and what
we're seeing constantly are it will is
an increasing percentage of students who
want to pursue tech careers whether
they're accelerating or putting into a
tech career and what we find is that a
lot of these companies want people with
a technical background so if you're
someone who hasn't had that in the past
and you obviously are interested in
pursuing an MBA having the joint degree
with electrical engineering is highly
valuable because you're gaining that
analytical mindset you're gaining those
technical skills and you're able to
approach these technical careers which
may not seem as technical on the surface
when you hear product management you
think about it maybe on the high level
more as a leadership opportunity or
maybe as almost your own mini CEO type
role managing the product but in fact
you know when you try to drill down into
it you're going to working with many
engineers and you're going to maybe not
necessarily code every single day but
you're going to want to be able to have
that credibility with the people that
you're working with and having that
technical skill set in conjunction with
the business leadership skill set is
highly valuable to a lot of employers so
again this past year we saw 32 percent
of our students going to tech with 18
percent of the students going into
basically an early-stage startup and a
lot of those roles would you know the
companies are really looking for that
technical background so the joint degree
would be a huge asset from that
perspective so it's really an asset not
only for people who are going into
technical companies but for many
students who are interested in doing
their own venture who are going to
become entrepreneurs absolutely yeah
from a from an entrepreneurship
perspective it's probably almost even
more more valuable because and if you're
studying something I've been working to
be working as from the business side and
working with a technical co-founder or
if you're doing you know the coding and
the development yourself then having
that analytical side we also
a really huge asset as well so do you
think Becky does that mean that that the
opportunities are really just in Silicon
Valley for people doing this joint
degree no I mean we're seeing kind of
the silicon everything going around the
world so you've probably heard of
silicon beach in Los Angeles
you've heard of Silicon Alley in New
York now Austin has a booming tech scene
and of course all around the world so
you're seeing a growth in China we're
seeing growth in Singapore we're seeing
growth in London across Europe so there
really a I mean the locations are pretty
much endless with the silicon
fill-in-the-blank so I see you think
that it's highly valuable around the
world
all right Mary back to you in terms of
the structure of the program and the
sequence when would a student be at
which school and and how many units
would they be taking sure so let me
start by focusing my answer towards
people that are not yet enrolled in
either program so this would be for
brand new people you can start with
either program if you start at the GSB
your first year you would primarily be
taking GSB coursework so MBA courses and
would probably have room for about one
to three electrical engineering courses
if you desire to take them and then your
second and third years would be a blend
of electrical engineering and MBA
courses and you can choose what blend
you wanted to do so you could primarily
one-quarter be heavy on electrical
engineering or heavy on MBA coursework
so there's a lot of flexibility if you
were to start at the electrical
engineering program you would spend your
first year primarily focus on electrical
engineering courses and if you wish you
could probably take a small number of
GSB electives and then your second year
you would be almost completely at the
GSB and again you would have an option
to take maybe one to three courses in
electrical engineering and then your
third year would be a blend of
electrical engineer
and MBA courses so overall as far as
units this joint degree requires 84 GSB
units and 45 MS units in electrical
engineering for a total of 129 and the
number of units are going to take per
quarter is really going to vary
depending on what program you're leaning
more heavily into so at the GSB students
tend to take a higher course load and
over at electrical engineering to take a
lower number of units per quarter just
due to the technical nature and hours
required outside of the classroom to
complete the work but we are pretty
confident that students should be able
to complete the full joint degree in
nine quarters and so if GSB students
average is 18 units a corridor
what would you say on average at
Electrical Engineering so as a students
I'm selling our MS&E program the
students are primarily going to be
taking 8 to 10 units okay which is about
three classes most classes in EE are
three units which requires anywhere from
two ten to fifteen hours of homework or
coursework group work outside of the
classroom so it is pretty intensive per
class I'm in terms of the hours students
are in the joint program they will
probably need to do one or potentially
more quarters at that 11 to 18 unit
course load okay now we know that all of
you on the line are here because you're
interested in the joint degree program
but after researching it you may find
it's not something you want to pursue if
that's the case Mary can't GSB students
take some classes over at the
engineering school even if they are not
enrolled in the joint degree program yes
that's a great question so built into
our MBA degree requirement students can
take up to 15 units of university
courses and so sometimes it's a better
fit for students to really just take an
area of focus and so they'll take 15
units of coursework in one particular
area so in this case it could certainly
be electrical engineer
and that would all count towards your
MBA degree okay and Katie can masters
and engineering students I believe they
can take classes of business school
sometimes there are a number of classes
that they are eligible to take and there
certainly are also outside classroom
opportunities we've had a long-standing
history of students working together
both with startups or in clubs and other
organizations going back and forth
between the GSB and the EE Department
so aside from taking the class worked
are a number of other opportunities for
students to really engage with the GSB
students as well all right well let's
talk about the application requirements
and the application process you do apply
separately to the two schools and let's
start with the application deadlines and
I'll just say that for School of
Engineering there's one deadline which I
believe is December 15th to set right
case I determine December 9th ok
December 9th 2014
so one deadline now what makes it a
little complicated is for the business
school there are three deadlines that
you have to choose from so you can apply
in October or January or April
we would suggest however that if you're
applying to the joint degree and you are
not currently a Stanford student we
would highly encourage you to apply in
the second round and the reason for that
is that you know you could apply in the
first round but you wouldn't know yet
you wouldn't get your decision back from
Electrical Engineering before the
deadline to respond to your MBA offer
and conversely you can apply in the
third round but you wouldn't know your
GSB offer before you had to reply to
school of Engineering's offers so if you
want complete information and know if
you got into both schools in order to
make your decision to come to Stanford
the best round for you would be round 2
now if you're a current
master's in engineering school students
then you could really apply in any round
so any any of those three rounds for the
Business School the application
requirements are as follows we require a
transcript we do require the
standardized tests but again if you're
applying to the joint degree program you
would want to take the GRE and not the
GMAT because the School of Engineering
does not accept the GMAT so if you're
looking at the joint degree please
save yourself some time and take only
the GRE if you are an international
student and you went to school where the
language of instruction was not English
then you do need to take one of the
English language tests but again school
of engineering will only accept the
TOEFL so if you're applying to the joint
degree program again save yourself some
time and just take the TOEFL although
the business school will accept some of
the other English language tests we also
at the business school requires two
recommendations and your first
recommendation must come from a current
direct supervisor at work and if you
don't have work experience that could be
from an internship or a summer job your
second letter of reference you have a
choice of either choosing another
supervisor if we scroll down here you
can see you can choose another
supervisor or you can choose appear
which is a person who's worked you know
on it on a team with you the work
experience I want to mention we do not
require work experience to to come to
Stanford in the in the business school
so you can apply as a college senior and
if you are admitted you actually
the luxury of being able to decide if
you want to come immediately after you
graduate college or we do offer
deferrals to college seniors of one or
two or three years we also ask you about
extracurricular activities if you have
them and lastly there's two essay
questions what matters most to you and
why and and why Stanford Katie what
about for engineering can you please
walk us through the application
requirements sure so for EE we have an
annual admissions process with one
deadline as Alison mentioned the
Shahrazad deadline will be December 9th
and students that are applying on during
the annual process they are admitted to
start in autumn quarter the students
that meet that December ninth on
deadline will be applying for admission
to start in September 2015 again no work
experience is required many of our
students do have some work experiences
from one to four years usually on
average to be eligible to apply to the
MS and electrical engineering students
must hold a four years bachelor's degree
from accredited institution and that's
the requirement from Stanford almost all
of our students that are admitted you
come from a stem science technology
engineering or math or hard sciences
background although it is not required
and there are also no prerequisites in
terms of specific classes but our
students do need to have a very strong
foundation and engineering and
specifically in electrical engineering
is strongly recommended because this is
a rigorous academic program your
application should really showcase your
propensity for graduate level study in
EE at Stanford so you'll find a list of
all of our application requirements on
our website and I'm not going to go
through each of the individual
requirements but there are a few that I
do want to highlight specifically the
GPA and GRE so one of our most
frequently asked questions is is there a
minimum for the GPA or GRE no there is
no minim
typically our students that are admitted
tend to be in the top ranks of their
undergraduate classes and then also in
the top percentile of the GRE we don't
have an average in terms of our admitted
students for the GRE however typically
our successful applicants are in the
90th percentile or higher on the
quantitative section of the GRE again
that's not an average is not a minimum
or a requirement it's just something
that we typically see in our successful
applicants I also wanted to discuss the
letter of recommendation that we require
a minimum and maximum of 3 letters of
recommendation and we should really be
coming from academic references though
people that can speak to your aptitude
for graduate study former advisors
professors researchers that have really
worked with you in an academic setting
so this is one of those differences
between the GSE and our application so
something to really take note of and any
essays yes we do have a statement of
purpose and it's just a very general
statement of purpose and that's your
opportunity to discuss how you're
prepared for graduate study what you
want to do your career aspirations and
again we're really looking for what is
your aptitude for graduate study in EES
Stanford and something that you want to
really showcase them pull out throughout
your entire application and I should
mention for the GSB this is Allyson
again that we also don't have a minimum
GPA or GMAT or GRE score and for the GPA
we're really looking at your academic
performance in the context of the rigor
of the institution and the rigor of your
majors ok I do want to ask you because
we had did have several questions come
in if somebody does not have a stem
undergraduate major are there certain
courses that they could be taking in
advance to prepare to make themselves
more competitive as an applique
for engineering sure there are any
specific classes and like I said we
don't have any prerequisite usually what
I tell students that are looking to
apply and that don't come from that
traditional stem background something to
do and that will be able to give you a
little bit more perspective is to take a
look at Stanford's explore courses and
people ahead and find the electrical
engineering department this is a list of
all the classes that are offered in EE
and you can categorize them by different
quarters most of the graduate level
courses that our students are going to
see in classes up to 200 level or higher
and so we recommend that prospective
students do is to take a look at those
200 level courses and see what the
prerequisites for the class are now the
prerequisites for each class are
determined by the faculty member and you
may have taken a very similar class and
undergrad and feel free to email the
faculty member and say hey I took this
class in undergrad it sounds very
similar to the prerequisite for your
class would this be appropriate or do I
really need to take the course here that
you've recommended at Stanford and
that's a really good way to gauge
whether or not you're prepared to take
these classes because the program is so
compacted and it is so done you really
don't have time to be taking a lot of
those prerequisite classes you want to
be able to jump right in and start
taking those 200 level classes for the
master's degree I think that's really a
great way to kind of gauge where you're
at if you don't come from a stem
background thank you I know we have some
current Stanford students who are
interested in the joint degree program
so Mara is going to have you address for
current MBA students what they need to
know and then Katie for current masters
of engineering or incoming masters of
engineering students what they would
need to know to apply for the joint
degree so if you are a current our
incoming MBA student you should apply
for the electrical engineering MS
program this year you need to do it
during your MBA
one year if you did not do it
concurrently when you applied for the
MBA all right yeah in the same case for
those currently students that are out
there you will need to be applying
during that first year second year
students are not eligible to apply and
the little only difference for the EE
students is that you have the
opportunity to apply it any of those
three deadlines any of those first year
GSB students that are out there they
need to meet the December 9th deadline
so just to be clear current second year
MBA students and current second year MF
EE students are not eligible to apply
for the joint degree program but they
could if they wanted just apply to the
other program and do it sequentially
why did you rather yes that's correct
all right how are we going to pay for
all of this I'm going to turn it over to
Jack Edwards to talk about tuition and
financial aid hi both having to talk to
you today the tuition cost then you're
going to be paying you'll pay six
quarters of GSB tuition tuition is fixed
for a two-year period so it's the same
rate so the incoming class say for the
class of 17 which will be getting the
class of 16 excuse me their tuition it's
right now is at 61 875 what's on the
screen is the typical GSB cost of
attendance so if you're going to start
the joint degree we recommend I
recommend from a financial perspective
you're going to want to start at the GSB
first because we do offer financially
for all three years that you're in the
program your third year tuition will be
billed at the graduate rate for the
university which is a little bit less
than what the GSB tuition rate is and
music yeah we have that up if we want to
go ahead and navigate to the graduate
engineering tuition rate so any
units are any quarters that are beyond
the six GSB quarters of tuition will be
charged at the Stanford Graduate
engineering tuition rate and that will
either be at the end eight to ten unit
ray or the 11 to 18 unit rate for
2014-15 they to ten unit rate will be
just over ten thousand or about thirty
thousand for the entire academic year
for the eleven to eighteen unit rate is
about fifteen thousand per quarter or
about forty seven thousand for the
entire academic year and in the School
of Engineering the academic year is
autumn winter and spring and and then
yeah for the six units of GSB I'll go
ahead and turn it back over Jeff and for
the six quarters of the GSB tuition we
don't know what the incoming rate would
be for those that are starting in fall
of 2015 you can project probably about a
4 percent increase in tuition cost and
so for the two years that you're at the
GSB rate that will be the same rate for
both years so in the financial eighties
is financial aid at the GSB is
determined based on financial need so
students have to demonstrate that
through submitting applications domestic
students will file the FAFSA plus a CSS
profile application international
students can file the CSS profile our
fellowship funds are use there is no
distinguish between being a domestic or
an internationally it's based off that
need so everybody qualify based off of
what their application and their
individual information is also we do
have a loan program specifically for our
international students as well so that
they have access to loans at a
competitive interest rate and
information about that is also on our
website so you can do some research and
you can see what types of aid are
completely available and so if you're in
the joint degree program you still
access to fellowship fun as well as the
student loans at for your third year and
again this is if you were to start at
the GSB right if you are coming if
you're currently already in the MFE
degree your two years here you would
have access to financial aid if you're
admitted to the MBA program okay and
when you say financial aid you mentioned
loans and fellowships it's typically a
combination I mean with one or two
exceptions there's really no full
tuition scholarships no there isn't
the expectation of that it's a
combination of fellowships and in the
student loans we look at all of your
resources and your financial and
determine your financial strength and we
take that financial strength and
subtract it from what that total cost of
attendance that appears at the bottom of
the page the total there and that
determines a calculation so there's a
total amount so we look at that number
and that's when we do the calculation to
determine so it's a combination of both
and so if you have external resources
that you may be bringing with you you
may have a grant you may have a
scholarship that is taken into
consideration in the calculation as well
and when does the process occur the
financial aid process so depending on
when you apply to the MBA program in the
round that's when you're going to want
to take care of applying for financial
aid as well to be eligible for the
fellowship you're going to want to make
sure that you're applying by those
deadlines there's a different deadline
for each round you're admitted in this
is after you're admitted after you
admitted to the MBA program so first you
would get your decision hopefully from
both schools in the and then you start
the financial aid process and if you are
completing all your paperwork by the
deadlines you will have a financial aid
offer before you need to accept your
your offer with the school so you'll
have four
nation about your financial aid offer
before you have to make it a correction
one other reminder is if your current
MBA student who's on receiving
fellowship and in for your MBA and
you're now applying to the masters in
electrical engineering and you get
accepted there
so you're you'll have one additional
year third year you'll be calculating
for eligibility for fellowship as well
as okay and I know some people in the
audience were alert too when I said with
one or two exceptions and are probably
wondering what those are well the one or
two exceptions is we do have a full
tuition scholarship for citizens of
India that's sponsored by Reliance and
we also have a full tuition scholarship
for citizens of Africa the Stanford
Africa MBA fellowship and we have had
one person
Mohamed's ask how does the Stanford
Africa MBA fellowship work with with the
joint degree if they were to receive
that power Chevy the Stanford African
MBA is strictly just for two years we
would recalculate you for eligibility
for fellowship for the third year in a
different format but there is there is a
available okay so you would still have
access to fellowship
yes funds for your third year correct on
that Stanford Africa fellowship and this
is true for the Reliant's fellowship for
Indian nationals it would pay for your
first two years and then you would be
eligible for financial aid for the third
year of dentist on financial need right
all right so let's talk a little bit
Becky and Katy about what the
opportunities are to interact with
Silicon Valley companies while you're a
student here and also just more
generally what students do during the
summer I think that there are a number
of ways that students can get cannot
connected with companies and internships
here in Silicon Valley I think many
times students and other and people
assume that it's our proximity to
Silicon Valley that says Stanford EE
apart from other programs and while
geographically yes it's great and it's
right in our backyard it's really our
history and our partnership with Silicon
Valley that's us thoughts apart
our faculty and students have they
played a very key role in founding
Silicon Valley and continue to shape
what develops there and so therefore
many cases our students are connected
with opportunities often through
personal relationships with both our
faculty and students but we also
formerly have many wonderful resources
on campus which include both the
computer forum and we can go ahead and
take a look at their website the
computer forum is a great organization
here on campus they are working
specifically for students that look to
enter careers in electrical engineering
and computer science they have over 60
members within Silicon Valley and also
worldwide
they hold career fairs resume workshops
mock interviews they do site visits
really great opportunity and then of
course we also have Stanford the reader
Development Center I mean this is really
more for a general audience they have
many of the traditional resources again
the career fairs the mock interviews
resume workshops but of course this
includes a very heavy focus on CS and EE
and they have dozens of connections
companies and opportunities here in
Silicon Valley and worldwide that's
bitter the perspective from the EE side
Becky do you want to talk about it from
the GSB fine sure thanks yes so like he
was saying there's a lot of opportunity
at the [ __ ] for one-to-one connection
networking that sort of thing and we do
a lot to facilitate that through the
Career Management Center we start off in
the fall for full time we have a very
structured on-campus recruiting process
so if you decide you want to pursue a
career at a large tech company we have a
large variety that comes to campus for
on-campus recruiting everything from
Apple Google Microsoft Amazon just go
into it you name it they're pretty much
interacting with us but we also have
companies such as Dropbox Box Facebook
LinkedIn these companies are coming to
campus as well for on-campus recruiting
we have an internship program with
similar similar listed
companies as companies come to recruit
on campus in the winter so in January
for internships and that's our
structured approach we put on several
company networking nights where these
companies will come and basically you
know mingle and interact with students
get to know them and understand and
students to engage with those companies
and understand what opportunities both
full-time and internship wise they can
pursue with those companies in addition
to that we also host a number of career
treks so we organize trips one of them
is called a tech crawl so envision we
call you know for those of you in the
u.s. you may be familiar with a pub
crawl or a progressive style dinner
where students will be on a bus and go
from company to company and meet at
their offices in San Francisco student
clubs also organize similar treks
so our entrepreneurship Club as well as
our high tech Club and a number of
others will organize treks to companies
around the Bay Area as well as other
locations so in the last two years
students have organized a trek to Austin
or South by Southwest where there's
basically thousands of companies to me
and the CMC the Career Management Center
also hosts an event called fewer than
300 or ft3 as we have abbreviated it in
which we invite specifically companies
about 30 companies which students have
indicated of interest to have a funky
Silicon Valley Stanford GSB feel event
so we've had some pretty amazing
startups come to that event and we've
had some pretty amazing decorations and
fun interactions where students have
actually sourced full time jobs and
internships so there's a whole slew of
opportunities with which to engage with
companies now for joint degree students
who would have two summers between their
three years would they then be able to
do a summer internship again absolutely
yes well I guess from the GSB sighs -
mobility absolutely I mean our students
are they're very much encouraged right
from the get-go to start planning for
that summer intern
after their first year and it would
absolutely be the case after that second
year and I think Becky really is a you
know hit the point you know well that
the companies are coming here to
Stanford and our stamps this to jam for
students really have a great reputation
reps representation out there in the
sunset and you know they're great
students and these companies are really
coming to find our students they're
seeking our students out and that our
students aren't going out there and
seeking out these internships that
really a lot of the opportunities are
coming to them I think that was
something for me that was really
interesting to see was to see these big
companies like Google and Apple showing
up and really sort of wining and dining
our students just even for internships
another which often turn into those
full-time positions right yeah I think
there are many opportunities and in a
way the challenge is to figure out what
you want to do and I think our Career
Center does a great job of helping you
figure out what it is you want to do not
just in terms of your job but how your
job fits into your lives would you say
absolutely yes so we have a number of a
number of programs - in particular one
is called career design which first year
students at the GSB will pursue it is
basically it takes place in the first
six weeks of your time as a first year
student here at the GSB and it basically
allows you to take some time to think
about what it is that you're interested
in what you're passionate about you know
what gets you going what do you want to
do from a short-term and a long-term
perspective we have a program also
called career and life vision or CLV and
this has a similar approach it's kind of
a program within the program that allows
you to not only engage with our career
advisors who can help have helped you
plan out your career in life vision but
let's say you you think you know what
you want to do when you really need
someone to talk through that process
with and we have plenty of people that
are wonderful support staff to help you
with that so there's a lot of
opportunity to explore and the Career
Center is not only helping you figure
out what you want to do but prepare for
your job search and interviewing skills
all the way to when you get an offer and
how to negotiate that salary all the way
to the end of the process in terms of
social life for joint
dual degree students as I mentioned we
have several other joint dual degree
programs here so we do have a lot of
experience with Mary in particular with
working with joint degree students so
Mary can you comment on what it is like
for a joint degree student in terms of
socialize do they sort of feel like
they're you know affiliated more with
one school or another yeah that's a
great question I think first of all it
depends on what program you start with
and that you're going to build
relationships with the cohort that
you're connected to so if you start at
the GSB I think you're going to feel
most connected to MBA students if you
start an electrical engineering you're
first going to build up kind of your
sense of community with those electrical
engineering students but what I have
seen happen in other programs is as
students start progressing through and
doing blended quarters they start to
build up kind of those social
relationships in the other program and
then they have what I like to call it
the first world problem of having to
balance the relationships at both
schools and then all of the events and
activities they're happening all across
Stanford and we're certainly not at a
loss of things to do events to go to
food to eat music to hear both here at
Stanford and just in general in the Bay
Area so I think students finds really
rich social life and sometimes you know
part of the draw for wanting to stay for
an extra year is being able to take
advantage of everything that the Bay
Area and Stanford University has to
offer
oh and I also want to add once you are
enrolled in a joint degree program let's
say you start at electrical engineering
but you've been accepted to the MBA
program you do have access to GSB
student activities and events and so you
are very welcome to come here and to
sign up for clubs and to attend lectures
activities whatever you'd like
so really the limitations are personal
of what you feel comfortable with
pursuing or not pursuing at your first
year here and kvr extracurricular
activities and clubs of engineering open
to business school students in the same
way absolutely I mean I think it
comes on what you're most interested in
but we have a number of different clubs
that are specific to the research areas
within EEE we also have a group called a
graduate student in electrical
engineering and I know that they would
more than welcome on students outside of
Electrical Engineering they do happy
hours and they do workshops with our
faculty so students are really
interested in getting engaged within EU
would certainly be more than welcome to
join us all right we only have a couple
of minutes left and so I'm going to ask
each of you if you have any advice for
our prospective applicants out there
either about preparing for the program
or once they're a student here's Katie
sure and I think I think I have two
little pieces of advice one would be to
start planning early and to get
organized early if that's possible and
then my second piece of advice is
something that I actually recommend
anyone that's applying to graduate
graduate school enough to do
informational interviews with people
that are in your dream job your dream
field on your dream career path and find
out how they got to that position with
degrees and they have also take a look
at what they would be looking at in
terms of hiring somebody for that
position now and just to find out
exactly what it is you do need and do
you need the dual degree do you need the
MBA do you need a PhD or do you need in
a math degree and that again is
something that I would recommend anyone
that's applying to graduate school so
you really hone in on what it is that
you need to achieve on your career goals
great Mary well I think Katie already
said it really well but what I would add
is that I think there's a lot of
exciting options at Stanford and it's
easy to get overwhelmed and so any work
you can do to get clear on where you
want to go what you want to do using
some of the strategies that Katie's
already mentioned I think are going to
come in really handy I find that
students who come in with a vision and
that vision may change
but hence they have a vision I think
they get more out of their overall
experience because they already have a
sense of focus of what they want to say
yes - and equally important what they
should be saying no - because there's
just so many things that you could be
doing to support your education so I
would just say take that time to really
try to get clear even if it's a general
vision but to have some type of vision
because the program's don't necessarily
help you find the vision the program's
help you get to your vision Thank You
Becky so I I totally agree with what
Mary and Katie have said I'm actually
going to talk about the informational
interviews with your dreams people in
your dream jobs as well so I'll get a
little more tactical on that front
so this may seem you know obvious to
some of you and for others and maybe you
seem a little daunting but I would say
in order to identify those people in
your dream job roles if you haven't done
so already take advantage of LinkedIn
you know go ahead and plug in a company
where you want to work or a function
that you want to pursue at those
companies you can go into your advanced
search in LinkedIn and just plug those
things in and see who comes up you can
plug it in by region so if you're
specific to the location you can add
that and obviously it's great to have
these meetings in person but if you
can't you know Google Hangouts or Skype
even just 15-20 minutes and someone's
time be sure when you go into those
informational Ziff it's over the phone
or in person has questions prepared in
advance be really thoughtful about what
you want to ask the worst thing that we
see is when students ask for an
informational with a great contact and
they show up and they haven't prepared
and they haven't done any research so we
know none of you will do that but make
sure you know you have those questions
ready to go
keep your requests short and sweet you
know 1 2 max 3 sentences about what you
want to ask for and then instead of
thank you so if you engage with these
people who have given you their time and
be sure to send a follow-up thank you
know again even if it's just three
sentences max that you know wrapping up
filling them in on where you're at in
your process they'll really appreciate
that check I think for financial aid
perspective just you can figure it out
after you've decided what's the best
pursue whether it's just an MBA just an
MS any
or doing the joint degree and if we
haven't made it clear earlier you can
apply to these before you arrive for the
joint degree program but you could if
you only wanted to apply for the NBA you
could apply to the engineering school as
a first year MBA student or if you end
up starting in engineering you could
apply for the MBA and add it as a first
year engineering student so you you do
have that chance to to take some time to
to think about it well I want to thank
all of you for your time this afternoon
I hope that it's been helpful to learn
about the program and whatever you
decide I wish you all the best